hallo ich bin gerade bei der messe in
waghäusel und beim bloßen wiesn tag und
ich finde hier ja eigentlich so ein
heimspiel denn wenn tirol ich auch und
wir haben die letzten vier tage jetzt
hier auf der messe ganz viel gebacken
und gekocht und meine zuschauer habe ich
versucht und heute gibt ein video von
der messe und zwar weil ich gleich hier
verstecken baku mit einer apfel zimt
füllung und streusel obendrauf meine
zuschauer sind mit dabei und dürfen das
später natürlich auch probieren
ich sag jetzt zuerst einmal den zutaten
für den hefeteig für den hefeteig
brauche ich einen würfel hefe zwei
esslöffel wasser etwas sein links trägt
80 gramm zucker einen teelöffel salz 200
mails etwa 500 gramm mehl und 80 gramm
reiche mutter jetzt die hefe auf die
content in die schüssel
ich bin auch dabei und natürlich auch
mitarbeiter im hintergrund da möchte er
nichts gesehen werden
höchstes und weiß was mit rein ich
möchte keinen appetit verderben
jetzt lese ich die regenwasser auf und
gibt auch gleich dazu jetzt haben
natürlich den vorteil dass wir jetzt
doch irgendwie eine zutat fehlt du hast
das du natürlich gleich einkaufen gehen
kann der kasberg hätten wir genau die
moralische immer für die zutaten zu
stellen musste mahle besorgen
soweit ich die liebe dann aufgelöst wird
kommen die restlichen zutaten mit rein
etwas vanille extrakt dass das öl nicht
fehlen so gut zum 1 1 rama man jeans
tragen die mädels kommt rein
doch mail
jetzt gebe ich auch ein tagesmittel ist
die temperatur oder punkten egal wie
temperatur und die butter ist eben weit
unter die beteiligt auch besser auch
wenn die zutaten nicht alle kabel sind
jetzt wird der teig verknetet könnt ihr
natürlich auch mit den händen machen
oder mit der küchenmaschine für mich
hier einfach mit der küchenmaschine und
dann las ich den tag getreten und dann
kommt erst die gute bilanz
mutter mal bringt einen ganz weich
für meinen kleinen stückchen und davon
derzeit sind gebläses jetzt gebe ich
ihnen auf einer bemehlten arbeitsfläche
und da wollen dann zu einer kugel
zusammen
da klebt jetzt auch nicht mehr
und da muss ich den tag erstmal aufgehen
lassen und kann ihn da zwischenzeitlich
die füllung und die straßen zu bereiten
für die füllung brauche ich zwei äpfel
ganze mandeln 200 gramm rohmasse 3 ist
ein extrakt zwei teelöffel zimt und 150
mm mädels immer ganz gern ganze machen
und mal gedanken oder einem organ
tribüne so mal selber weil das argument
viel besser ist und ich dann eben auch
was drin steckt
wie machen es einige kein mix art die
mandeln ja dann kauft man sich gemalt
oder oder lässt man mit dem meine
moderationen geschirrtuch eingewickelt
mit dem hammer drauf gehauen 15 30 also
wie gesagt entweder wieder in der
küchenmaschine oder mit einer küchen
reife
die erste mal in dem haus gemeldet auch
ein geblieben
natürliche zutaten kurz und davide die
schüssel etwas zu klein
und dann gebe ich ihr die restlichen
zutaten noch mit dazu und kann alles gut
miteinander verrühren
den zucker könnten natürlich auch
weglassen durch süß genug ist ich habe
jetzt auch nur zwei esslöffel rhein noch
etwas vanille extrakt das ei und die
milch und wer gerne mit gibt es noch
zwei teams sind mit aktion
mit alles ganz gut miteinander verrührt
erstmal weg stellen natürlich auch eine
andere führung machen zum beispiel die
füllung auf meine musik video aus dem
ersten ich finde die füllung allerdings
auch ehrlicherweise sehr aromatisch
schmeckt und durch die äpfel wirklich
auch ein feuchtes und marzipan und sind
sowieso in der kombination sehr gerne
ich verrate ich noch die streusel zu
dafür brauche ich 150 gramm in 100 gramm
käse butter 100 g zucker und eine prise
salz
jetzt kann ich die flughafen wieder in
der küchenmaschine zusammenfügen oder
eben auch mit den händen
jetzt kommen butter und zucker mit rein
und es wird jetzt alles erstmal
betreiben
der sowieso streusel und dann können die
sich ganzen verbinden und so sollten die
streusel dann in etwa aussehen
die stelle ich kurz zur seite und griff
schnell meine backbleche david fitz
super aufgegangen
dafür solltet ihr im westen zwischen 30
und 60 minuten aufgehen lassen bis er
sich verdoppelt hat so gebe ich ihnen
auf ein etwas bemehlten arbeitsfläche
und david loosen recht ich ausgerollt
das recht ist wirklich mal 60 zentimeter
haben
die teigplatten mit der füllung
gestrichen
damit der teig karte geht es nun auch
wissen schneller salz zwei wirklich
große firma könnt auch zwei kleinere l
zu nehmen
aber wir kriegen das schon alles unter
weil ich jetzt hier auf der messe bildet
kleine hebel schmecken machen deswegen
teile ich die platte jetzt noch mal
durch zwei ihr könnt sie aber auch gerne
im ganzen lassen und einfach etwas
größerer hebel stecken zubereiten zu
rolle ich die von der langen seite her
auf am besten ganz ganz fest
schon jetzt die rolle so ein bisschen
sehen dass sie gleichmäßig wird und dann
will sie in etwa zwei bis drei
zentimeter dicke stücke geschnitten
hier befriedet die einzelnen teile um
und habe dann besser kleiner schnecken
und die kommen jetzt auch ein backblech
jetzt habe ich alle hebel teile
zubereitet und geformt jetzt kommen noch
die streusel obendrauf und dadurch dass
ich als diese marzipan und abfüllung
drin habe brauche ich jetzt die teilchen
auch nicht mitmachen so bekämpfen die
kleben auch so dran also die streubel
jetzt die hilfe schmecken so weit fertig
jetzt kommen sie bei mir in den karten
backofen und vatis wegen weil ich sitze
immer aufgehen lassen
falls sie jetzt auch noch zeit und ihr
könnt sie noch eine halbe stunde
aufgehen lassen
dann wird es ab und dann können dass sie
direkt in den heißen backofen schieben
während die ersten zwei bleche jetzt in
den ofen backen können die anderen zwei
bleche aufgehen und die dürfen und
später einen heißen backofen
die werden jetzt bei 180 grad für etwa
25 minuten gebacken liste gekommen sind
und dann machen nämlich heraus und
vielleicht ihr euch dann auch
gebacken und ich habe jetzt bereits zwei
flächen oft holt die allerdings beim
packen jetzt gerade noch jetzt kann man
sich nicht so auch schon servieren oder
macht noch einen wustrau oder bestreute
mit diesem schnee ich werde es noch
einen bruder zu wohnen drauf gehen
manchen geschmack das wirklich gut dazu
passen mir das sollte der zitrone und
mit ein bisschen puderzucker gebe ich es
hier etwa 1 2 esslöffel st
in einem chip und da computer zucker mit
drei bis vier esslöffel das eben ein
dicker guss entsteht
also ich mache ein bisschen merkwürdig
aber auch ganz viele teilchen jetzt ganz
glatt rühren wie sich das ändern lässt
oder mit einem teelöffel geht's auch
andere über die teilchen drüber und dann
darf leicht einen zuschauer oder hat
auch mehrere noch zuschauer dürfen
gleich probieren müssen auch ganz eng
sein
jedenfalls scheint es hier ganz gut
anzukommen und valerie dieses rezept
auch noch mal machen wollt geht aufs
tennis - block data stets noch mal für
euch der moral statt weil ich wieder
hinter dem vorhang herauskommen wir
standen die kamera gleich aus und jetzt
gleich noch ein paar bilder von der
messe die letzten vier tage jemand
wirklich schön und ich freue mich auch
dass er da sage ich noch mal bei allem
besucher haben sich hier wagen und ich
freue mich auch schon auf die nächste
hallo
entweder ich bin an diesem samstag am
neunten tippten in balingen besser
gesagt in frommern und zwar bei unserem
guten freund marc von koch blume bahn
ist in schwaben lena da kommt ja der
murat er und der markt hat einen
lagerverkauf und da wird jetzt am
samstag eine neue führung stattfinden
das von ihr blut und kornblume genau da
sind wir mit dabei und werden mit marx
zusammen für unterhaltung sorgen wenn
ein paar kleine leckereien machen
für essen und trinken ist gesorgt die
feuerwehr immer feuerwehr ist mit dabei
und der gesamte erlös des essens wird
dann auch gespendet an wohltätige zwecke
und italien in balingen und am tsv
frommern geht und wir würden uns freuen
wenn ihr auch alle mit dabei seid uns
dort besuchen kommt wir werden da sein
von morgens bis abends das event geht
von 10 bis 18 uhr
doch nicht so mitarbeiter mag ist mit
dabei und ganz viele unserer freunde
natürlich auch und ihr könnt gerne eure
ganze familie nehmen eure kinder
mitnehmen und es wird wirklich richtig
toll
der arbeitskreis mit dabei und ja und
einem satz von 10 bis 18 uhr eigentlich
ist aber wir wissen service open end
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen länger gehen
und ist meine heimat
dabei waren ins kabel entlang genau wer
noch nie dort war es wird schwer uns zu
verstehen denn richtig schwer geschwätz
verstehen uns wahrscheinlich selber
halbe dach also bald vorbei kommen
wollte würde ich mich natürlich sehr
freuen
ich freue mich auch schon ganz auf den
mag und mit dem trinken sie übrigens von
den messen der böckler uns mit auf die
messe erwartet wo ist niemals ein paar
wie das war schon mit aber genau der war
auch genau noch mehr dabei und das ist
mein freund ich sage ich nicht sein
freund er macht sich lustig über mich
aber diesmal am samstag wenn es ihm
heimzahlen
ja wenn ihr mit der feuerwehr trockel
samstag bis samstag tschüss